I want to announce some new Return of
the Rat tour dates January 26th
Louisville Kentucky January 28
Indianapolis
February 2 Shreveport Louisiana
February 3rd and 4th Baton Rouge
Louisiana March 24th Corpus Christi
Texas March 25th and I believe 26th
Houston Texas
uh we just added a new show there in
Houston April 26th and 27th Phoenix
Arizona May 13th New York City we just
added a show there
uh June 1st and 2nd Austin Texas and we
will be adding new shows as current
shows sell out so if it sells out just
check back you can use the code Rat King
if it's before Friday November 18th
um if it's on Friday November 18th or
after then you can just buy the tickets
as you go go through theovan.com
t-o-u-r and uh to make sure you get
accurately priced and thank you so much
for all of your support
um I'm so grateful to have this
opportunity to get out there and see you
I love you guys gang today's guest has
been uh he's been on quite a ride as a
human as a um
as a content creator uh he's
he's one of a kind there's no doubt
about that
um
he has a new special Jew out on YouTube
and uh and he's gonna tell us a little
bit about the Journey of creating that
and and I'm just grateful to get to
spend some time with him uh while he's
out here in Los Angeles uh he has tour
dates and everything you can check it
all out today's guest is Ari shafir
I don't want me
[Music]
I sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Music]
he says she came to Nashville remember
yeah dude
that was cool man that's ruined a lot of
me but not not all of it
um yeah I've been good man just still
slowly just getting over I mean my
burnout was so bad it's tough to say
that to people because people don't know
it but like I couldn't even sit through
a conversation well there's a
conversation I did with this guy Bryce
Mitchell where I could barely even talk
I was just my I mean just got burnt out
you know yeah so it's just been a slow
like you know every couple weeks I feel
a little bit better I got on like some
peptides and I got like uh a lot of
different vitamins and
did that Ayahuasca thing to try to get
better man I tried I was trying
everything to kind of you know see what
was going on
I was telling Bobby it needs to take
time off I was telling them yesterday
and it was he was like yeah I gotta do
this in this mic dude you're saying the
same thing everyone's saying and I was
saying that like you and I were talking
about it yeah you and I appreciate you
hitting me up you hit me up and say hey
man you remind me to take some time off
to go do some things for myself
um but I said how like the comments were
all like yeah Theo go we'll still be
here like go get right yeah comments
weren't like no you better not take off
the comments were like shocking the
other way like yeah why do you think we
get that feeling then that we can't uh
that we have to keep going
what do you think some of that comes
from some of us to drive within like
where it's like we had starvation
mentality for so long you know that
we're still like I gotta work I got a
job I got an offer for a gig and you're
like kid those are we have to be
comfortable
you know like like
you know you raise poor if you're like
hey the [ __ ] free breakfast stops it
at 10. we gotta get down there and then
at some point you're like I'll just go
buy breakfast you know and you're like
all right yeah I guess I don't need the
Continental like like you got to just
convince yourself that you're you're
fine
that's a good point I think some of that
probably some of that realization too
some of that slowly coming into my own
head like everything's gonna be okay
yeah
um I yeah I remember we get the
Continental dude my mom sometimes we
would go meet my grandparents and we'd
stay at like this Howard Johnson hojo's
bro oh they had it they were nice they
were nice they had a nice eating place
in there yeah you could eat there yeah
the waffle maker God cause then you
weren't just eating good you were you
were like contributing yeah yeah you
were there you were like go make it like
I can make a waffle
waffle oh never mind the concierge right
like a French chef now yeah
then you'd forget about it you have to
turn it over
bro I wonder how many losses there have
been of people who like just like
thick [ __ ] that tore their Rotator it
was pretty lawsuits too they were like
this guy [ __ ] burned himself like
yeah you know how people are Hot Irons
will do that oh you let your
seven-year-old yeah I probably shouldn't
have done that before that one [ __ ] at
McDonald's who [ __ ] spilled coffee
and then she sued in one at that point
everybody had to be like hey no more
freedoms for you guys they've ruined it
all man I used to love the freedoms
because yeah then Anything Could Happen
you mean you'd meet a guy who like uh
you meet a kid and his eye was like sewn
shut from a waffle from like a hot
waffle iron tell me your story I try to
restart remember no face at The Comedy
Store oh we had a comic name no face
because he had like [ __ ] Mack the
Knife face
because he tried to fix a [ __ ] one of
those like things in the back of a boat
those uh those Motors
yeah it's like I know I can fix this
he's Trucking on it and then he's like
he just no faced him
he was not a great comic he's like in
his whole his cheeks got remixed huh he
just got [ __ ]
he was he had all the sympathy but he
was kind of a dick too and so you're
like Heckle oh but you knew he was him
heckling because you know it's like dark
in The Comedy Store you're like who's
that because every heck would be like
you suck
that's like air was escaping from his
lack of face
oh my God tell a better joke
huh
sometimes the weirdest fans come out
there was a guy who came to his show and
he's like man you got to meet my cousin
he's the biggest fan of yours he lost 70
of his skull right
oh damn wow and you want to be like tell
me about the 30
well he would take his hat off and then
he would go
and his head would literally go like
that dude I'd be like cartoon surprise
he would go and you see
oh how do you lose the skull I don't oh
they went into it man it was I thought
it was gonna be a little bit smoother of
a deal you know it was something
um
I want to say it like uh some some of
those like electronic double doors or
whatever you know oh like at a you know
a you know like a Chase Bank bit him or
something on the way in or whatever and
it just didn't read a soul it was like
closed I think it's just like yeah and I
guess the argument in court was that his
soul wasn't showing up on those monitors
so it wasn't their fault yeah yeah I
should have gone to church more it
wouldn't have been an issue you go like
this in the elevator
hey buddy your soul ain't showing up on
here you know dude I got back from um I
don't know where I was France and I got
that uh Global Entry so you don't have
to do a meeting if you're just like
Andre on your way back you can do it so
I'm sitting there waiting some lady was
like oh hey I'm a fan of yours I'm like
oh what are you getting your Global
interest because no I'm like
they're not registering my daughter's
face she went full goth and then the
machine is like this ain't her
damn I guess it can't tell so maybe goth
is the way out of all of this maybe
goth's way out maybe Marilyn Manson fans
because you don't see a lot of like
Asian Marilyn Manson fans or things like
that you know or like uh
um who is that lady who sang happiness
uh it's a warm gun no no singer Florida
yeah you know she sang a song they'll
never play again it's like about getting
beat up really uh hit me what is it
kiss with a fist oh and they don't play
it much anymore with such a good [ __ ]
banger
it's like feel something over nothing
yeah and then she's now she's like yeah
well that's interesting because some
people use violence as their form of
affection that's pretty wild
um Jew man let's talk about so let's
talk about you have you have a new
special Now new special so the Journey
of this special is interesting because I
remember
yeah because I remember when you were do
you did this like you had started this
kind of years ago right yeah five and a
half years ago wow yeah
yeah it was it was uh
canceled a couple times but you know you
stopped me on first down a second down I
still got third yeah I picked it up you
know third and fourteen I picked it up
two more Chase over here dude you're
[ __ ] God yeah
um well congratulations man thanks yeah
I watched about the first 20 minutes so
that's as far as I've gotten nice that's
more than I can watch most Comics even
to put it on is to like is a is like a
is a nice compliment yeah like hey I
loaded up your thing yeah even if it's
like I loaded up I asked my mom called I
forgot to you know but like just to load
it up it's like cool well you know every
comic is like we know them all so we
can't watch them all yeah I um yeah and
I love the candles I love the setup kind
of it felt a little scary kind of a
little bit it felt a little like uh we'd
gone down into a hole in the desert and
you were kind of telling me some stories
kind of a little bit yeah it's got that
campfire Vibe versus like religiously
kind of feel yeah Indiana had a little
bit of an Indiana Temple to do kind of
vibe a little bit for me yeah and you
will waste your soul away I'm gonna
steal your [ __ ] heart if you watch it
too much efr all right if you watch it
three times yeah and then it's like what
does it really say when he was like a
resort
what is this what did he say he has some
words
in Indiana Jones yeah pull it up there
Charlie Mar something like that oh yeah
huh [ __ ] I know it it's close I'm close
um
so that must have felt great huh yeah
yeah I felt great and it was interesting
because if you'd have done it in the
beginning yeah it would have been for
Netflix no oh it wouldn't have been yeah
okay sorry I thought that it was gonna
be for Netflix and then now I ended up
on YouTube and that would have seemed
like almost a better
Choice uh yeah it was always going to be
YouTube it was kind of like before
people were putting them on YouTube I
already thought of like no this is the
way it's like you can get it to
everybody you'll be like early on a
platform
um you still own it you still own it
sure they can't stick some [ __ ]
lady's name on the end of it as a
producer I never met once in my life or
ever talked to like who the [ __ ] is this
lady you guys just stuck on the end of
my [ __ ] yeah I think credits are
important you can't just stick some
[ __ ] lady's name on there uh they'll
yeah they'll just
sticky texting bro yeah I'm like what
um
so yeah and and it honestly was bet I
got to like go back
to these jokes like with like a year and
a half off and go oh some of this is too
long these setups are too long I like
some of these like oh this is the same
joke twice I I can't see if you know
forest for the trees kind of [ __ ] and
then I was able to like edit a lot
better it was a lot better because of
all that how much is it to shoot
something like that
this one cost me quite a bit
um they're expensive aren't they yeah
you can make them for for very little
and you'll still get the jokes across
you know
it'll still be good but the way I wanted
to make it it costs it costs it cost a
lot a couple hundred g 230. wow yeah the
song cost 20. yeah isn't that crazy
you're like oh this song would be great
in like it's 20 grand you're like it was
it was it was uh it was um what's his
name uh Louis Armstrong and it was it
was eight grand I was like okay wow
that's not crazy [ __ ] that's a lot of
money but I'll pay for it they go well
also there's like a chorus he uses on it
so you got to pay the chorus guy also
I'm like how much is he he's like he's
10. I'm like what and they go yeah and
they have favor Nation so it's 10 and
10. oh what we're from eight to eight
Nations they're both from Africa aren't
they
yeah that's the favorite Nation Oh I
guess it is now huh yeah it is now it's
a favorite Nation I got a promo shirt
let's get it out
um there we go Ari shaffir Jew dude no
more hiding that's right these shoes are
out of the out of the attic into your
into your homes I'm coming out of the
attic dude I'll say this about Anne
Frank's Place I went there yeah it's two
bedroom two bath massive overlooking a
[ __ ] a river bro it's nice perfect
location yeah there's coffee shops
everywhere what a wonderful spot I will
tell you this I did it on my last
special there's a there's like a brunch
place if you're ever in Amsterdam right
below Anne Frank's house so Anne Frank's
around the corner and then below it's
like two steps down it closes like 3 P.M
the best grilled cheese sandwich I've
ever had in my life I mean it is out
like use four cheeses out of this
[ __ ] world just stop it
[Laughter]
you made a joke last time that I missed
that I saw some comments I'm like [ __ ] I
felt so bad I missed it I forgot what it
was and it was like what a [ __ ] idiot
when a comic just like uh-huh
uh sometimes you get stuck and broadcast
you're listening you're trying to be
involved in it
um thank you thank you so much this is
like I'm just I'm happy to be able to be
in a conversation and have a good time
yeah
[Music]
so some serious ones uh no just I just
haven't you know like it just like it
feels good to [ __ ] just be having fun
you know what else feels good the Great
Taste of Celsius because it feels good
going down it's delicious and low
calorie I assume uh it might be actually
only one serving per container you don't
get less servings than that
yeah what is that
thanks Celsius all right dude it's funny
because I'll pass up my morning coffee
and I'll I'll just wait until I get here
to have this does it have caffeine in it
it has a little bit oh I need some it's
nice man
um so now because you now Jewish stuff
is like it's been like hot recently
right yeah yeah so it was higher now was
that a part of the reason was it were
you just happen to be putting it out
probably putting it up I was gonna do
Rogan's podcast we're gonna do a sober
October wrap up and I was like I had it
and none of these bits are like
are like timely they're all five
thousand year old Source material yeah
you know so it's like there's no there's
no rush or not rush yeah you know I took
my time editing it I went to Paris for
like a couple weeks and people like
where's the edit notes I'm like yeah
yeah yeah sorry sorry like you're the
boss or you're waiting on you I'm like
[ __ ] yeah but then um I was gonna do
Rogan I was like that's a good time I'll
just do it the day after I do Rogan's so
as soon as it comes out I'll just have
it and then [ __ ] it blew up yeah well
gold digger [ __ ] talking to the
[ __ ] backlogs and started promoting
it that's awesome yeah
um and does it feel kind of like because
you've had some moments of like kind of
like rock I don't know if it's Rocky
moments and you your world some hurdles
yeah I mean you like to be on the you
like to you like to play track and field
yeah so I just throw that pie yeah you
like to be out there baby people get I
swear the pot so much people around me
get enveloped in my potstick
sorry dude I got soup on my feet from
you bro sorry about the soup
yeah
waiter there's a lawyer in my suit
I feel like yeah if you have my back on
your podcast there's a chance you're
gonna have to contact a lawyer at some
point
um but so that had to be wild then so
did you feel like oh my God this is like
Kismet or whatever that I'm I'm putting
this thing out and now all there's all
this Jewish like uh anti or Semite stuff
and stuff happening no I thought it was
gonna be the end of it again I thought
it was gonna go fourth down
yeah because I saw a world
where they were the reaction to that was
going to be overly protective and they
go anything that's even remotely
anti-semitic where they wouldn't get a
joke they don't know what irony is you
know anything remotely we're just
killing it so that we don't have to
worry about being called anti-semitic I
could see a world with that what
happened there's a chef you can pull it
up I don't know if you can this guy has
like a pancake mix company black guy and
and the logo of his company is is him
with one of those big Chef's hats and he
you know he like was promoting his stuff
and Instagram or Facebook doesn't matter
same same they they're like that's
racist take it down damn and he goes
what rate that's me it's my company
they're like nah it's racist he goes
what racist I'm him and I'm a chef
they're like nah dude come on that's
racist
it might not be uncle peace it's someone
like that [ __ ] that's Masterpiece that's
Masterpiece it ain't that one
yeah and it's like and it just looks too
reminiscent so they went overboard and
they [ __ ] didn't let this guy promote
his own black owned business
and so I could see a world where that
would happen and I get it also from
their point of view they're like I don't
know damn bro yeah these all look so
racist though everything does damn black
people look racist well I think it's
like if black people are in the kitchen
you can't be in that you can't be
cooking anymore blacks oh dude if a
black guy even brings my food out I
don't even know today he's like hey
you're doing this because you want to
right you're free of your own volition
to come and go
[Music]
just kind of signal in some way
oh yeah
so I was worried about that happening
really because that's funny because I
would think the other thing like people
would be more there would probably be
more support for it you know sure but I
was like I wasn't looking for that when
I thought of putting it out so I was
like don't let it go away oh there is a
world you could see where that could
happen oh totally I mean it's hard to
have any type of um it's hard to have
any type of irony these days you know
um did you feel do you is your
especially is it anti-semitical no no no
no that's not the word but um uh no it's
not it's very reverential and whatever
but also like yeah you make fun of
yourself yeah yeah remember Stevie Z he
died uh Davey Wester
oh yeah yeah he died nope nope sorry
dude oh damn he's still living still
with us
but you know he has cerebral palsy when
he fell since he's our friend people
would have cared more right there if he
said he died probably which is a sadder
products hey Davey if you're out there
and you want to help this podcast kill
yourself
kill yourself I didn't the views of the
guests on this podcast are represented
by the podcast itself kill yourself do
it kill yourself
God I feel like I'm in the cheapest uh
Saw movie okay that's old
it's like did you have like a trap nah
we couldn't afford that well it's like
that girl that texted her boyfriend he's
like oh my car's broken now she's like I
bet you won't kill yourself I was like
damn maybe I should kill myself like
have some balls dude think it out yeah
that's what you told him you don't have
any balls yeah I'll show you yeah do
something else dude damn dude eat some
[ __ ] Brother cakes don't [ __ ] get
out there or not yeah and take your own
life hey have you ever been on
Squidbillies no you should get on that
show people always ask me about
Squidbillies that's one of the best
shows in the world and I just I saw
something I thought was a squid and then
you it's that on that belt it looks like
squid legs oh yeah you should do squid
bellies man they would love you
I would love to be on that but you
should be honest I think I've reached
out to him about trying to do a cartoon
or something at some point and they
didn't want to do it oh Adult Swim is
done now anyway yeah Adult Swim [ __ ]
somebody pulled the drain
um did um
did you because did you feel like was
there a lot of uh
because it's not anti-semitic but it is
making fun of Rome so I was gonna say
when Davey Wester would like [ __ ] me and
Renaissance saw debuts are trying to get
a straw in his mouth but you know those
double doors the saloon doors the store
and we're looking he was trying to get
strong because like like missing it oh
yeah and man we were dying and then
eventually he like Seas were laughing
he's like [ __ ] you guys
and it was so [ __ ] fun because we
love him and we're like we know this is
your disability and you're trying to
overcome it and that is funny that
you're failing oh totally man I mean
it's I think some of that is interesting
because I'll have a friend who will like
go to therapy all the time and I know
and that I mean and even myself and
that's our disability and there's times
where I laugh at it if a friend makes a
joke about it I laugh you know it's like
it's funny it's like a dark like I
thought about killing myself again
you're like I know you're serious yeah
it's funny yeah yeah yeah sometimes you
want to be dark yeah
um so yeah no it's not automatic but
there is like some making fun of Jews
there's a difference is there yeah
because I feel like sometimes you can't
even say Jew and then you everything is
anti-Semitic it's it's literal people
it's going like like um like you you can
make fun of the president you could be
like uh oh the president fell off his
bike and you're like why do you hate
America you know right and it's like no
I'm just making fun of his [ __ ] his
shirt's untucked yeah like you can you
know oh totally there's this uh Bobcat
Goldthwait had this great story about
being on a on a plane and there's a
bunch of down syndrome kids on the plane
and they had to make a semi-emergency
landing I think they couldn't figure out
if the wheels could come out or not and
they didn't know so they're like hey we
have to burn off fuel we don't know if
it's gonna be a crash landing or not our
sensors aren't working
um we're gonna have fire trucks like on
the premises waiting for us you know and
all these downstairs everyone's so
worried these downstairs because like
fire trucks fire trucks and now there's
a person that goes well airplane jokes
are hacky and you're like oh no dude you
don't understand this at all yeah
they're trying to weigh in yeah yeah
dude this is about perception yeah yeah
yeah
um interesting man I think uh yeah
because that's one thing is sometimes
it's like you can say almost anything
but if you say the word Jew then people
and it makes it oh is this right yeah is
that a no no it makes it not even fun it
makes it like I can't even get scared to
joke around with some of my Jewish
friends or I feel like I need to ask
permission if I can joke sometimes like
I don't know yeah you know what this is
a weird world that we're now you listen
to these [ __ ] dorks too much and you
start feeling weird and you're like and
you realize mostly of us are just Comics
like we're cool you know there's all
every week somebody walks out angry from
The Comedy Store or from one of your
shows probably too you know you're doing
a thousand people in a night two people
are gonna leave angry yeah you can't be
worried about them sometimes you see
them leave somebody see him leave yeah I
gotta complain in in um Chicago two
separate couples old couples left five
minutes apart their kids told them to go
see me and they both said the same thing
to the management it's not enough that
he's making fun of the death of children
it's in everyone else is laughing about
it they're racking them on and it's like
yeah get out of here you're not four
here you can't stop doing it because of
those two dorks their kids are probably
sitting home like we knew this [ __ ]
hate yeah
[Laughter]
um what do you think about this all
right we got some news that popped up
here man they speaking about what's up
we're talking about the fishing Scandal
people oh yeah did you see that they're
going to jail those people go to jail
over some [ __ ] trout are they going
to jail I think so yeah wasn't it so
crazy the guy's just standing there can
you bring up that that fishing skin
[ __ ] Lance Armstrong skated on it and
these fishermen are going to jail those
days I'll take it seriously Swamp People
don't [ __ ] around
the French are like you learn your
lesson but they swamp people like nah
dude you gotta be punished two minute
cues of cheating in an Ohio fishing
tournament Scandal have been indicted
indicted is high level arrest is it well
apparently these guys actually like they
they like five different guys they took
away their like yearly income because
like this the amount that they want for
this is not a small amount yeah what do
you win what if you're the top level
[ __ ] let's guess what do you think
this tournament oh oh this tournament
alone I think top prize 28 000 oh that
might be too high
no I think I was gonna go 35 000. let's
see it's uh 29 000. damn
and I don't want to say the J word right
there
cut to the organizer I think yeah
Larry David Silver's gotta get his cut
yeah
oh my fish Burn Fish steam yeah trout
Bert trout steam
um uh this was a wasn't this crazy
though they put weights in it but they
they were just too it's like those guys
taking roids like take a little bit of
roids don't get the [ __ ] Barry Bonds
bionic head yeah you take too much just
put a little bit of weight in there put
a [ __ ] one gold coin in there
don't you don't want to pick up this I'm
like it feels [ __ ] like 80 pounds
what the [ __ ]
yeah every one of the fish it was crazy
because they'd have like a huge fish and
then a little fish and the little fish
was weighing the same guys
what the [ __ ] crazy yeah like
something's up like I don't know what
you're talking about apparently like a
bigger fish ate one of the little fish
and just sunk to the bottom of the uh of
the pond and they ripped these dudes
they ripped them apart and the one guy
stood there like he didn't know I would
have jetted yeah go go get on your
[ __ ] speed boat and go your lips go
live you know how to you you've taught a
man to fish you can do it you know not
as well as the other guys but you can
earn yourself a [ __ ] meal yeah yeah
oh I would have been out of there man
beats Amanda cheating fishing and I'll
fish it did God just pull I mean he
pulled a kettlebell I love that they
were like it's like a man got caught
cheating he was like wow that's crazy
fish must have been eating lead weights
yeah yeah
oh my God damn these fish must have been
hot
wow pieces of other fish you should have
just done that oh it's very Dom or ask
when you get to that part
he's just standing right there he's like
watching it
you guys
wow refund all that [ __ ] so what did
he get it and then we got home with it
and they came back for another time
we'll go on Zach
I think they win money throughout the
season so they're like this is just now
you got to give back everything it's
like why Barry Bond's not in the Hall
they're like we don't know when this
started oh it's true he was you could
see a guy being caught he's in the most
in the midst of freezing
flight or fright or freeze you know and
he's just like he's just hoping it ends
he doesn't know what to do yes he should
get the [ __ ] out of there yeah you guys
should just run yeah no they'll chase
him down that now that's a good point if
he starts running he'd have been
probably a dead man yeah it's like if a
dog's barking out if you start running
that dog is gonna get you oh it's true
huh yeah yeah there's something about
that once you run it makes something
else want to chase you don't stop don't
let him run yeah you have to be calm and
calm them around you yeah cheating and
fishing we found that money it's just
it's part it's sad it's just kind of the
world we in a lot of cheating out there
you know a lot of people were just cut
in Corners I guess but I don't know
everybody else here seemed pretty pissed
and seemed like maybe maybe it's just
these guys
sucks you're [ __ ] playing a game you
were cheating the whole time
so I was like what the [ __ ] come on
that's why I love a Tour de France when
they took it away from uh
Lenny Armstrong oh yeah and they were
like we gotta give it to the guy who
came in second place and like nah he was
roiding too and they're like [ __ ] third
like Royden you know how far that 17.
they had to give to the number 17 guy
and I'm like he didn't even finish the
same day he [ __ ] finished on Tuesday
he all came in the [ __ ] you know
through the palace on Sunday you think I
rolled up took a break stop for the
night he goes man I've lost I don't know
and then he's like tortoise in the hair
you know as long as you finish who knows
because he's not even a cycle it's just
a black guy in a chef's hat
he's an Uber Eats guy and he's like oh I
just came to the [ __ ] play Royale
um did you see this he saw Trump's back
up Trump's back up what let's play hard
on
no if he got a heart I mean he's oh
Trump in order
my candidacy for president of the United
States
I love the breaking news at the bottom
Trump expected to announce presidential
but at any moment like yeah he just did
it [ __ ] ticker there with it ticker
you're [ __ ] behind the times
yeah ticker's almost like that autistic
buddy you have a ticker and that was
always a name they had for somebody that
had autism or whatever ticker because
he's a tick ticker button hey Button
where is this tell them button
Mar-A-Lago
it's Mar-A-Lago what do you think about
this he's gonna win right
what do you think I don't know I don't
follow politics at all so I'll follow
him much either it does it is
interesting because I like the tears of
the of the righteous and man this guy
makes him flow
fun for me to walk their tears were you
even when you saw Dave Chappelle saying
that did you see that bit that he talked
about Trump he goes I'm not I remember
him before he goes but when he was
running he goes I'm not going to vote
for him
I'll vote for Hillary but I don't like
it yeah you know yeah do you see that
can you find that Zach where he said the
other day during his SNL thing
about what thing why people liked Trump
which is the original trumping out damn
so he's eight years past where he was
before he was already old then
you think he's still [ __ ]
yeah you think Trump's still [ __ ] I
think one of his top goals I think he's
getting probably ex-homes and stem cells
into that it's probably smart to take
the four years off because then you
extend you know your time being at the
top you're on four all four but that all
four you're still former president he
still is yeah and then on four again and
then the next four you were just the
president so you really get 16 years out
of that if you run it right and you get
to bounce back and kind of like see
whatever didn't work maybe the first
time I don't know if in Trump's case
he's able to do that you know what Trump
you should change the Constitution to to
eight consecutive years so that way you
can you can do it eight full years this
time
that's what Hitler did that's what Halo
did rewrite that Constitution did he
yeah you breathe out that Constitution
anything goes did it in Ecuador too
rewrite the Constitution damn yeah
ecuadora yeah I knew a real liberal
comic and she couldn't understand she
was like what the [ __ ] when Trump won
and uh and I was like well you've never
gotten under your limo you've never gone
to Dayton these people are depressed and
they're looking for answers you you've
never talked to them you live in your
[ __ ] gated apartment building
you know when no one's allowed in you
have your [ __ ] doorman wearing an SS
outfit yeah like you have no idea what a
human is like so you're like what like
right right you've sheltered yourself
yeah the media went so far overboard and
tried to discredit them that they
eventually got caught like just
misleading the truth yeah remember that
Russia thing never was anything not
always never anything was invented by
Hillary Clinton's side so let's just say
she didn't know but it was invented by a
democratic side and pushed so that and
they never go oh [ __ ] maybe we got to
look at these Liars over here they just
go move past it so it was like if you're
not going to apologize it's like if you
tell me you're gonna pick me up from the
airport and then you don't and you never
apologize
I don't think you're gonna pick me up
from the airport next time I can't trust
you're gonna do it if you said dude I'm
so sorry my alarm didn't go off it's
like I can tell you're sorry yeah but
these people never owned up to anything
I did and so it's like I heard I was
randomly in my car and I was listening
to Trump on like NPR during the State of
the Union Address or something and he
goes uh this MS-13 this [ __ ] group
from Mexico that's like the drug dealers
and [ __ ] Smugglers and those are
terrible people they're they're they're
gang members
um and they're rapists and you know
they're terrible people and then the
headline I was like oh I wonder how
they're gonna play it the headline the
next day is Trump calls Mexicans rapists
yeah and I'm like damn it's not a lie
but it sure ain't the truth and
eventually I did it so many times we're
like we don't believe you guys
yeah I think well that's one thing I
think people don't believe the news
anymore some people still do believe the
news and I'm not saying believe the news
in favor of any person yeah I haven't
seen that Chappelle monologue but
they're like oh it's anti-semitic I'm
like I guarantee it's not yeah I've seen
enough of these every time you see a
comic run too far I'm just like without
watching it no he didn't yeah but I
think that's one thing that's what
that's the thing that I originally
thought was fascinating about Trump I'm
like he's not a politician he's not a
politician so he has the chance at least
if it's possible just speak real to get
in there and and do at least put shine
of some sort of a light on whatever we
don't know yeah because he's not one of
the two sides he's not part of the
[ __ ] Garden yeah everybody's looking
out for himself and business interests
too much it's too bad you get sort of an
evil one in there for that doing that if
it would have been somebody else it
could have been interesting Bernie maybe
or somebody who's like hey come on we
gotta help you let's get these guys out
of prison he's talking normal not like
and we're gonna take it and we're gonna
go to the Washington and we're gonna
turn into a little over there it's like
[ __ ] you you ain't one of us yeah
yeah I think he got then I think his I
think at that point something they just
wanted to change I think people like
[ __ ] the system that's what they want
they wanted [ __ ] that that's what how
come all these billionaires got more
billions during covet when we're all
suffering I know who's doing that and
rich people making Rich laws for rich
people yeah I can't afford a lawyer when
I get arrested they just have my
retainer so of course they're gonna get
off easy well it does start to feel in
the world like we gotta go to where
they're doing it we gotta climb some
walls we're gonna take care of business
yeah but it's not the guy I feel like it
used to feel like the government was the
best I don't know if I I feel the
government's bought out right but by
that businesses they're one step down
yeah the businesses put the government
in charge to like keep us all going
that's what it seems like right yeah
yeah it's like an owner and then the
government is like the government's like
managerial they're like supervisors
that's what it feels like yeah yeah like
they'll get theirs too you know they'll
make sure to get theirs but they're not
the real ones right they're just kind of
a liaison now between big business and
human regular regular folks yeah yeah
that's what it feels like anyway not to
be a downer but that's that right there
is what I thought was fascinating about
Trump from the beginning was like [ __ ]
maybe there's a chance yeah where she
goes she goes uh you're cheating on a
taxi goes I know I'd be a fool not to
yeah what do you mean yeah I have great
[ __ ] taxes attorneys the rest of that
clip there might be it might be on there
that was basically the end of that club
okay
well okay
see and that could be we don't know if
it is or not but that could be it's not
out of context book no just big digital
telling us that's the end of the class
enough I got a call it's actually the
end of the clip yeah oh okay
please use Crest when you're brushing
your teeth everyone yeah it's white
Smiles of crust you could do no wrong
yeah sorry about
sorry about something
um does that feel like what it's getting
to sometimes do you feel like overlords
it can't say certain things do you feel
like we're getting there
dude I had Milo yiannopoulos on my
podcast you did yeah a long time ago
um and he's like kind of like a gay
flavor flavor right in what way like
he's like a height man or something he's
a hype man he's a troll oh he is he says
stuff just to piss people off oh and
then it does piss people off and they go
you're so [ __ ] it and they hear these
gay he said he's married to a black dude
oh he's murdered a black dude yeah oh
wow he's so liberal but he's
conservative and so he's like the the
tears of the Liberals get me hard oh
yeah yeah so I had him on my pocket just
talk about how he's a troll and not this
like evil whatever and he keeps trying
to go into him like Hey you're not
fooling me you know that that this thing
the white power sign so he goes him on
on 4chan which I think is not a [ __ ]
it's it not this evil it's it's a troll
group right I think what's the best way
to troll people is go conservative that
people hate that so it's like then do
that you know right I always say online
yeah online so I go let's invent a fake
a fake sign that means nothing and they
go let's do this we'll call it white
power
so then he's like all right how do we
get it out there and they're all like I
don't know let's just let's go slowly
we'll see whatever and then Milo's just
with the president randomly you know on
a on a platform and they're all taking
pictures and he goes oh [ __ ] they're
taking pictures and he just goes like
that yeah and people like what's that
sign and then they showed those [ __ ]
kids the one that was the Indian was
yelling at oh yeah and they see them in
their basketball look they're going like
this yeah they're like no that's a
three-point the Curry's doing that yeah
it's like they don't even understand it
and he got them all upset and now
there's a fight it was even better yeah
now there's a fight between the left and
the right you can't take away our this
sign weird [ __ ] you it's racist and it
means nothing he trolled them both I had
in my podcast all right I was just
talking about trolling and the origins
of it and how he does it and I got
demonetized on YouTube no yeah I had to
start a new account you can no longer
make any money on YouTube for just
hearing that we're wrong about him
hmm it's wild so yeah a few times you
gotta like consider it but at the same
time it's like ah I make money on the
road
you know yeah you've always been brave
you've always had that you know like
you've always not really mattered where
the spoon is coming from as much or
that's what it seemed like yeah yeah
it's like yeah Patrice would talk about
it if you owe them they're gonna call in
that favor you know it's like ah just
like guys we got to be true to ourselves
and at some point it's like well we need
to do this like I don't wanna
all right that's not funny I don't want
to do that oh yeah you know well that
great that that that's definitely I
think happened over the years especially
with like Holly with like you know like
Comedy Central sent me some offer the
other day it was like six episodes of
something and it was like 1500 an
episode or something you know and it was
just it was very nice yeah but it was
like
I post three shows to you guys that you
guys [ __ ] passed on and then now you
should just like don't you have any
[ __ ] couth even as a as a you know
it's almost like you walk past me a
million times in the dog kennel and then
finally now when I have a king's dog
yeah exactly like come on I've got an
owner you come by and ask me if I want
to [ __ ] come and I got some great
advice from Eddie Griffin once
he told me uh I booked my first
commercial it was like a big commercial
back then that was like some level of
success you know and all the I remember
this chick it was a doubling this you
never give me the time I just literally
wouldn't say hi back to me when I said
hello hmm then I'm on a commercial and
she was like oh hi I saw your commercial
I was like you treat me well now
I tell Eddie Griffin about it goes so
what's your question like he was already
made it a little bit he's like so like
you don't know how to like treat him
because they were like such dicks to you
and now you know they're only being nice
because you're doing well I was like
yeah he goes here's what you do
have sex with them wow because that's
your revenge have sex with them oh
really huh yeah if you're good at sex if
not it's just [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah it is it is shitty Robbie from uh
from when he was still at uh uh Montreal
he would do this great thing where he'd
call people like Whitney and he'd be
like just to call not to do anything to
get them going just go hey sorry I
missed the boat on you I know you
showcased your new faces a bunch and we
didn't take you and clearly looking back
we were wrong anyway don't offer
anything I just want you to know that
and if Comedy Central called you with no
offer just say hey Theo and it wasn't me
I wasn't in this position before but
someone else here was so I know you
blame the whole company just so you know
we're happy for your success clearly we
missed the boat so that [ __ ] us over
yeah and we're sorry about that I hope
you're having a good day yeah there's oh
it would have been nice there's nothing
like nothing but then if they come to
you six months later like hey you want
to do this I did like maybe you guys
seem cool
that apology I didn't pick you up from
the airport I should have I'm sorry you
can't just skate by it yeah you gotta
own up to it that's fascinating man
that's a good point
it's a real good point man I think a lot
of that is just like yeah making some of
Man's having some uh I didn't do that
right and I'm sorry it's just like I've
had I mean I've had people turn on me
left and right so you know how few of
them ever said hey man I I shouldn't
have done that okay forgiven but most of
them just go I hope it goes away yeah
and then when you become successful like
my friends have they go how you doing
I'm like you don't think I remember
uh they don't they don't
that's the worst man I've had it you got
another Celsius back there uh Zachary
can you have Colin grab one
thank you that's the worst one I've had
friends that have gotten successful that
had done me wrong and I still had to be
like not like subservient to them but I
I knew I was never gonna get
any like apology or something you know I
guess that's just life though huh yeah
I've had people um thank you
that's five cents
I've had people apologize to Rogan about
what they said to me and it's like uh oh
what a weird Hollywood thing you'll say
you're sorry to the famous guy
because you're afraid he might turn on
you
but never to the guy you actually
wronged hmm or your way to the famous
guy called you out and go okay I
shouldn't have done that and it's like
be a [ __ ] man man or woman but be an
adult it's hard and most of the women
are trying to be men let's be honest so
it's like be a man be a man yeah be a
[ __ ] man be a man Ladies sorry I got
us off on a not funny chat yeah yeah
yeah
um what about dating what's up in the
day in the love life I don't know yeah
yeah yeah welcome dude it's butts man
they're so hungry for my [ __ ] are they
really yeah have you been doing even you
don't do gay stuff huh sometimes yeah
get in there mix it up I've never done
it man I uh I think if I was in like the
mill
or a war or something maybe yeah how
long in the zombie apocalypse would it
take for you to [ __ ] a [ __ ] a butt
no women man or woman
have you ever [ __ ] a woman but
I've probably been all right yeah
I've done what I could anyway it's a
real it's
it looks easier on in a draw you know
it's still good to still do hugging
conventions it looks easier and Oh you
mean the orgasmic meditation conventions
the huggings you go over and like cuddle
with people no I never did that what I
did was the orgasm meditation what is
that they just had a documentary on it
actually I just watched a little bit of
it I know all that was just meditation
it was called One Taste
this was a program
I thought you had to go over and keep
keep women good company yeah
so this was the program man it's so
funny you mentioned that dude you have
such a good memory sometimes yeah short
term gone long term is still there yeah
I talked about it 10 years ago that's
what this one uh they had us they had
this orgasm Incorporated she's cute she
can get it that she can get it she is
the creator of it I think her name was
Audra something she can call yourself
whatever she wants so she um this was
orgasm meditation I got invited by
the lady that does Tommy Pickle's voice
on Rugrats right so she invited me I met
her on a podcast
and she invites me down to this
meditation thing her brother I think had
been in prison and he was there
so next thing I know I walk in it's like
this kind of nice Ambiance it's in a
warehouse downtown and there's people
like having like uh
little you know cantaloupe and
everything like that little tray of this
and that little meat select meats and
stuff like that and so I'm having a nice
time and then we all sit in the chairs
they start telling us what it's about
and and then it's a it's called orgasmic
meditation then they get a woman up
front on this table and they take her
underwear off and then she like
has her legs open yeah this is it kind
of she has her legs open on these
pillows and then the man puts on gloves
and they just pick two people out of
this I mean it was like Red Rover Red
Rover what
so this dude is like oh man it's so
embarrassing too like uh you might oh
it's like in class when they're like who
knows the answer and you're like don't
call me don't call me yeah and this is
like raising your hand but with your
[ __ ] and so you gotta go in there and
just [ __ ] well they teach you how to
do it they teach you how to use you just
use one finger and you do a certain
amount of lotion and stuff like that and
first you have to describe the woman's
uh vulva maybe or something I don't know
what it's called uvula
[ __ ] yeah yeah you got to describe that
and it's kind of crazy because sometimes
you're like man it looked like you know
it looked like it looks disgusting it
looks like somebody made it with a
shotgun you know but then somebody
you're like especially in serious
medical help yeah sometimes you're like
man this thing looked like a damn paper
cut but a [ __ ] positive attitude on
it you know like so sometimes it's it
was but anyway you had to do that and
then you had to sit there and they had
like a certain way you had to kind of
uh pleasure the woman uh
uh clitoral stimulation and the the boss
would walk around and tell you how to do
it
so you would um like a yoga instructor
is like no no get your back yeah oh wow
and it would be 15 minutes of pure doing
that and you do that you reached in a
[ __ ] you have gloves on
so it's almost just like dying here it's
almost like dying your sideburns or your
beard I mean it just you know it just
takes a little while in a way I'm sure
it is in another way yeah it's really
different than that
but it was crazy man and then at the end
you all hug they do a big team hug and
you never [ __ ] no but there's people
that want to I mean like you're must so
then you get on the message boards and
now you're driving over to people's
houses during the day and stopping over
and one lady over on Laurel Canyon up
there her dog [ __ ] that's when I quit
her dog bit me while I was doing the
thing you know and she wouldn't lock the
dog up and saw him fighting with this
lady or you know her pants or just the
whole it was like this is too much I
don't want to get a charge or nothing
and I'm not doing anything bad you know
but it was sometimes you go over and
then they want set you get them all
wrapped up yeah they're like hey yeah
you're like I'm just trying to do the
program dude because it'd be matched up
you get matched up with a 70 year old
you get matched up with like a 21 year
old yeah and then you turn on I heard a
story about red fox
he would ask somebody to go to The
Comedy Store The Waitresses his office
was like down the street from the store
and he said go ask those hot waitresses
you know guys whatever to come over to
my place
it's a red fox wants you to go over
there it'll give you 500 dollars he just
wants to go down on you hmm that's it
and like what do you mean because he
wants to go down on you they give you
500 bucks and goes I don't have to sex
like nope 500 bucks wow he'll go down on
you I'm like well okay celebrity wants
to go down I made 500 bucks not bad I
don't have to do anything once you're in
there he's going down you know goes hey
500 more let's [ __ ] and you're already
in the mindset you're already like have
this guy licking your box and you're
like all right [ __ ] it yeah let's go wow
you wouldn't have gone for a thousand
for sex
incrementally so what is that is that
like uh you're already [ __ ] rubbing a
chick's [ __ ] monkey yeah and then
it's like oh well don't leave so soon
and then he leaves and he's like now you
know why they call me red fox
maybe he's like the menstrual starter
and he just like starts it's like yeah
the menstrual show yeah you're worried
you're pregnant
dude and he's just wearing a chef's hat
[Applause]
so racist oh those are your kids uh
those are my nieces and nephews they're
good kids they're pretty the one's bad
you can see the one it's bad which one
is he
that one he's got problems oh he does
actually he used to hide on the shelves
and you come in a room and he [ __ ]
like a damn really gargoyle yeah he was
real wild uh have you had the chance to
be an uncle or an aunt all right I have
an uncle a ton are you yeah I'm the cool
Uncle my brother thought he was the cool
uncle and I was like why would you be
the cool Uncle he's like what do you
mean I'm like cool I'm like
Michael I I like I [ __ ] hookers dude
yeah what are you talking about yeah I
I've traveled the world that yeah you
might be a cool uncle in another family
right I'm a stand-up comedian dude right
what do you get casual Fridays yeah
bro I'm the cool Uncle yeah I'm the cool
Uncle they're all when they want to
experiment with drugs who are they going
to call you you or me yeah me yeah yeah
that's true huh there is something fun
about being the cool Uncle also there's
something that gets weird for me about
being the still single the still not
married uncle right do you start to feel
that at all like you're at an event and
you realize oh my God everybody here
has a spouse or a significant other yeah
your friends from high school too where
they're like what or they'll live
through you you go to the beach weekend
with them like you're gonna try to [ __ ]
I'm like no I'm here with you guys we're
playing can jam yeah
he's trying to [ __ ] and I'm like guys
relax yeah yeah and the only person
around here is your wife yeah so I don't
think you need to be making this stuff
on and besides he hates you she's gonna
leave in about six months exactly I can
see it I've seen breakups you haven't it
ain't going well
yeah it is weird because you also start
to be like people are like I don't know
guys are like I don't know if I'm with
that guy around some single guy and and
then also the wives start to hate you
yeah the wives and then the kids will
get into college and then my dude I had
a buddy of mine's kid was flirting with
me and I'm like Jeepers Creepers man you
know really an adult you know yeah but
22 years old yeah yeah but I'm like shut
this down you know you gotta [ __ ] her no
you gotta no I'm sorry dude the ruling's
been made uh it's out of my hands now
and then it's a black dude in a chef's
hand it's like [ __ ] buddy dude I'm
always telling my buddy's kid to like
she's like kind of not shiftless but
directionless she's like she went to a
year college and now she's trying to
figure it out and I'm like tell I'm like
hey you should go travel same as I tell
you but I'm like especially a 20 21 year
old I'm like it's the perfect time take
that Gap year find out what you're
interested in go to South America and I
don't tell my buddy that I keep telling
her that you know because I can't
believe are you telling my [ __ ] kid
to leave the country you know and I'm
like I realize your kid's friend yeah
I'm telling her like real advice it's up
to you to let her not go but yeah that's
true huh do you um she saw my special
sorry if you're Jew on YouTube yeah
yeah she loved it people are liking it
have you noticed that uh there's been a
good uh well I guess you'll probably
start going out and touring more now or
what's kind of some of the plan after it
it is a plan and you want people to see
you people want to see you people will
um you know I'm gonna get lost a little
bit you know take a little vacay go to
South America so where where is a place
that actually what's a place because if
I'm not doing drugs and stuff what's a
good place for me to go oh my God so
many um
okay what interests you Maui I like
usually okay let's go deeper than that
okay we were further away that's another
country all right what do you got what's
what Clause at your head you know you
gotta you got some weeds in there what
you've always been interested in I like
Spanish
okay what about Spain
what about all of Latin America and any
any countries like kind of pop into your
head of like let me just throw some
names out Belize Guatemala Nicaragua
Nicaragua that'd be cool
Argentina would be cool have you been
there no I would love to
yeah go to um what's the main city in
Argentina uh
no no Saint Paul's Brazil
um
Zach doesn't know it
I thought I'd need it off the top of my
head
yeah I should know it I know we all
should Buenos Aires Buenos Aires start
there take some Tango classes
Tim Ferris went there a long time ago
yeah and then fella Nova Tango lived
there for six months taking Tango
lessons wow
do you think yeah go there there's
grapes and then go away from the city
you can get an Airbnb to have a home
base there
and then like go on little trips and
come back to that Airbnb take my podcast
stuff do a couple episodes down there if
I need to a thousand percent you could
do that especially you do a solo a lot
right yeah sometimes next week is solo
guys well dude then yeah
and the devil's experience has come back
whip out a few I just did this crazy
trip doing this so I took my first
Hangout to an hour on that
and then like the next day like I had
another crazy experience weighing
against space them out you know release
them every week oh if you could take
your podcast [ __ ] there for sure find an
Argentinian comic oh who speaks English
or does any Argentinian a hundred
percent interview them regular people
[ __ ] where is the place yes you could do
that that is a good idea I wonder if
right after Christmas I have some time
here's what I told Bobby because he's he
said you might guys might be doing
something and he goes uh he goes well so
I gotta finish whatever he's finishing
and whenever it is
and then he goes then I might have this
thing I'm like put it in your contracts
ahead of time you you can't you're done
no matter what it's the whatever deal is
finalized you're done June July you're
not available we can start in August and
they go well we want she's like it's
already my deal start in August yeah
talk to Theo ahead of time have your
same take the same [ __ ] time
two point of stairs you know how jealous
I am just hearing that the thought of
that is a possibility is that fun oh my
God take your pockets look at me to take
some Spanish classes go there and just
take enroll in a Spanish class
you know it'll give you some like
Direction every day you'll meet some
other people in the class plus you'll be
a nobody which will be cool yeah you
know walk the streets no one will look
at you no one will say anything to you
yeah and you can do your podcast from
there God damn it you've made a [ __ ]
perfect life
[ __ ] I'm legitimately jealous at the
thought of that I'm jealous yeah I'm
jealous of the thought of it too and it
could be a reality it could easily be a
reality
grab this [ __ ] mic and just take it
unscrew this thing
um what's a place where you've gone if
you're doing so just so our audience
knows if people want to meet uh great
food where do they go because you've
been so many places Thailand is great
food uh um Mexico is like the star of
Latin America yeah food but but I mean
there's also great food everywhere but
like
trying to think Europe is not as great
for food finding a wife where do they go
Vietnam Cambodia yeah you can [ __ ] him
get yourself a nice one dude I went to
it I mean an actual wife not a sex oh
people like Costa Rica oh yeah I learned
to Surf yeah down in the Florida Keys
yeah it's a different place but yeah
where else dude uh uh uh dude I went to
look for some live music I was in I
think Cambodia and I was like it was my
day my psycho geography the death I'm
gonna find some live music I'm gonna sit
with my notebook and do some writing
couldn't find it eventually he was like
oh I think there's some in this bar like
only on Monday he's like [ __ ] and then I
kept all night like look found some and
it was just an 80s cover band and it was
a sex bar wow that was all these old 62
year old men you know with their young
women and young men really yeah and they
were all they had a community and so it
was cheesy [ __ ] beach rock you know
uh playing cranberries and [ __ ] like
that and all these dude yeah
so you guys gave me a [ __ ] yeah and
they're not in a rush because these
girls are hanging out with them you know
and they're all talking about they're
all smiling ah because they're not
worried about some chick bringing them
down
they're just like you have eight dollars
wow you can change my life yeah it was
so cool dude I would love to see you
host a show like a 90 Day Fiance or
something like that because I feel like
you'd have such a good
take on where these people are from and
some of the Ambiance of these countries
and the reality of them staying together
and the [ __ ] you know yeah if you
did a recap of that I think talk to him
like what's it like no judgment yeah no
judgment that's the key no judgment
because people go over there and they
you know somebody gots a little calf
with them or something there's a lot of
Dowry going on and it's like you kind of
don't know what's going on 702 they'll
be your tour guide sex person for like a
week or two and then they're just like I
love you but it's like a girlfriend
experience and then they go hey I'm
having trouble paying my rent do you
mind sending me like here's 500 bucks
and every year they're like hey my son's
having surgery he's like he's 500 bucks
they get six or seven of those guys on
the hook they're making their living
[ __ ] 500 bucks every two months with a
different guy
they used to have a guy with a lot of
Nigerians dude and uh or nigerias
whatever they call them but whenever
they um were doing that thing where they
were scamming people on the internet
scamming people's grandparents oh yeah
there's a comedian whose his
grandparents got scammed right so he
started do his grandmother got scammed I
wish I could remember his name
was it Bob Saget he works at Bob second
it was Bob oh what happened about second
well there was another guy that happened
new yeah and it uh I'd like to replace
instead of like saying people's names
I'll just replace them with Dead comics
you know so this did happen to Bob Saget
oh no I think it was Louie Anderson this
afternoon okay all right okay so his uh
his mother got scammed so then what he
started doing was he started saying that
he started contacting these people and
saying all right I'll give you this
money he didn't they didn't know it was
the grandson
um I'll give you this money uh if you do
a reenactment of like the intro to
um
uh are this scene from Seinfeld or any
Cinema link to the scene and then he'd
have like four Nigerians send back like
a spoof like uh and he just kept putting
these together oh he played a couple of
them for me it was so ridiculous so
Tebow does that Jason Tebow does that
with like with like sex like hey I'm
horny and he's like what are you up to
now yeah he goes back and forth with him
on like DM
and he's like I don't know if they could
have killed myself what you up to like
uh I need a man and goes yeah it's cool
um I read any good books he just refuses
he just keeps them on the line it's so
great oh it's so fun to [ __ ] with him
back like you're not gonna get me
yeah that's sick man getting the yeah I
think getting that sex getting into that
sex work I wonder if that's how bobby
gets that got his Twitter hacked oh is
that what happened I bet he he was like
he was like somebody was like you're so
hot he was like well let me send you my
passwords I bet it must have been who
gets scammed if you're not a grandma did
his Twitter get hacked I didn't see that
what'd they do send out nudes or
something
no they're just like give me money hey
I'm I need to can you wire me 200 bucks
I I gotta make bail I got a buddy like
that
we knew a guy who got the Nigerian scam
these guys used to hang out the store
these tweets are protectors this counts
locked now we can help Bobby get his
Twitter back let him know if they're
protected by Stevie he's [ __ ]
um uh yeah and he said it all his
brother was like he's acting like a dick
tall of us what's going on like we're
acting like a Dick's like I'm about to
come to some [ __ ] money you guys will
all be sorry and they're like what like
yeah dude instead of just being a
complete [ __ ] to everybody and like
where are you getting this money he's
like I know a guy royalty is getting out
and I got off and they're like what like
he fell for a 22 year old no and they're
like that's a scam it goes no it's not
and they're like where's he from Nigeria
and like he was like
it's not a scare just realize like
that's your natural state is to be a
dick
and yeah money will make you it'll make
you see some things about yourself man
we gave Eddie Bravo a a red banded we
were on the road I think was in Boston
with Rogan he got one of those fake
scratch off tickets
uh handed out a couple like losers and
one winner they always sell them in like
three so everybody's like here I got
everybody scratch-offs he gave Eddie
Bravo the fake one
it gets two like cash cash he goes whoa
and we're all like I was like I lost you
know it means I got [ __ ] lost too and
he's like I need one more cash sign
and he [ __ ] hits it we let him play
he's like oh my God I want ten thousand
dollars this is crazy and we're like
wait and he goes rabbit I'm giving you
five thousand dollars I'm giving you
five that would circle of the whole
drinks are on me and he was so nice
we're like oh [ __ ] oh we were like
hoping he'd be a dick you're so nice
like I gotta break the news to him
we felt so bad oh I'm dying I'm glad you
brought him I gotta text Eddie back
actually even saying that makes you feel
like dang I need a message I
um what else do we have some more news
that came up
yeah we got some stories here okay um
well Elon Musk apparently fired a
Twitter employee who disagreed with him
you must love this Ari huh I love it you
must love this world because Elon is now
this sort of Geppetto of this world that
was really that we we don't need Twitter
we don't I deleted mine a year and a
half ago it's such a toxic place it's
such a you can't say anything like oh I
like this Cactus like well there's a lot
of other [ __ ] vegetable fruits and
trees that need help too and you're like
oh it's just it's only there for
apologies and
wow actually spoke out in Twitter and
even the company's private slug yeah I
guess a developer like was kind of Elon
tweeted something about like the
infrastructure of Twitter and a
developer was like he's wrong and then
yeah oh guess what these people lost
their way this gen Z and even some
Millennials they think they're powerful
you can't publicly talk [ __ ] about your
boss
it's like what world did you grow up in
well you could just [ __ ] on your boss
and think that's okay and they all do on
slack they go over people's heads that's
why New York Times can't write a real
story because you go over your boss's
head to your boss's boss and they go hey
are you not uh printing the stories of
the young black people and like no I'm
putting the stories of [ __ ] college
kids that's why I'm not printing it's
like what and then I will be holding to
the [ __ ] employees instead of the
employers and Elon Musk like nah I built
a billion dollar company you know nah
yeah no you're fired get out of here but
that lady who walked out on Chappelle
got uh uh uh made as a guest on SNL for
the [ __ ] eighth time you know it's
like oh I'm walking out it's like or you
can just write a pro-trans [ __ ]
sketch and make him be in it yeah you
know you actually have a voice you're
gonna walk out if I was that boss like
don't come back it's okay that's fair no
your voice your opinion don't don't come
back
we we booked a guest and you're an
employee here you're not allowed to walk
out do you think Hollywood has narrowed
itself into a hole I mean I think a lot
of like you can't even make fun the only
people you can make fun of any more
Russians I feel like or even then look
Top Gun they just go the enemy they
can't even make fun of Russia yeah or
poor white people they still make fun of
it poor whites yeah most of your family
they're like Theo's family string them
up I think that's why you get a lot of
people that are so like Aunt again
Christians yeah yeah
um yeah you can't make fun of Jews you
can't make fun of blacks you can't I
can't gays my new special artistry for
you on YouTube right now guys I'm
[ __ ] broke please go in there watch
it donate I need some [ __ ] money that
can't afford Pizza I do one thing I love
doing Special was the special is free
right yeah and then one of the first
comments was it was like uh who says
Jews never give anything away for free
now go donate exactly yeah I'm like
here's this free thing but give me some
money yeah but it was I thought that was
really really cute though but that's
cool yeah guys check it out and make a
donation there to uh to support the
freedom of Comedy also too you know I
always wondered if guys like Rogan would
uh create a platform that people
subscribe to you know that would be cool
I could see Segura doing it too like a
five dollar a month app right on your on
your Apple TV and you get a special a
month special a month just content just
content's coming out and don't worry
it's going to be funny because a guy in
charge is like we want funny right will
you have black people yeah sure we're
booking funny people how everybody yeah
but we're not going to behold we're not
going to be like [ __ ] we haven't had a
I don't know Arab comic in too long just
but get some open micro they're not
gonna do that you know
so yeah that would be great and that's I
guess a lot of things get put on Rogan's
shoulders I guess hypothetically since
he's such a force you know but yeah guys
like said girl or even if like a group
of comedians partnered up and said okay
let's create this platform we'll each
put a special on it once every two years
so you know what they say like you make
money on YouTube right they said look if
you see the so if you're making money on
YouTube and they're selling ads YouTube
is making money most of them right
probably 80 90 of it
um which is fine whatever that kicks
them down so it incentivizes you to put
stuff up
but what if we just made our own
platform and we put stuff up on YouTube
and there this other platform where we
get all of it minus some operating costs
we just get all of it that'd be a lot of
money yeah you know if we're making 10
of it and you can make I I so far three
and a half million hits on that I think
I've made like 25 Grand in ad revenue
and that's 10 of what they're making so
what if I made 250 well my specialty
paid off
you know
it's true who's gonna make maybe a few
Comics the dreams out there I don't have
the wherewithal someone needs to put it
in and I've I've mentioned it I've
mentioned it to some other comedians I
think it's
it's hard to make a platform that
actually works well doesn't lag and [ __ ]
like that but right I think you would
get together because say if you got you
know if you get a million people to
subscribe at five dollars a month they
know they're gonna get one ads even free
just come here and then the ads come in
just like here but we get it all
right I guess I was thinking of
something that just had specials on it
that too that would also even if you
started with that you just had specials
yeah a special a month for five bucks a
special a month for five bucks you would
need a lot of subscribers because if you
had 50 people wouldn't pay for it right
you'd have to have a say if you get a
million right yeah which I think say if
you had enough certain comedians you
could get them all to say split it up
right you could go buy views you could
decide after the interview a year 50
million a month
oh my God yeah so no no no five million
a month oh if you got a million people
five dollars good call yeah damn it was
like what it's gonna be true and that's
why you got swamp math I need an
accountant that's why you need it that's
why you needed that's why you need a Ari
shaffir Jew on YouTube you gotta have a
partner in crime yeah
um but five million a month so that's 60
million a year
so now we're working on it so then if
you paid the comedian say you gave each
comedian whoever's gonna put their
special on you give them two million
dollars
right yeah further special and then you
said also in three years you get the
special back it's returned back to you
you're always on this just here sitting
here right it'll sit here for a certain
number of years and then at a certain
number of years it'll go back to you
yeah and then every month you did that
split up by downloads whatever and it's
also hey if people are coming here to
watch specials keep it up there right
you know yeah you can keep it on YouTube
as well sure but you're getting less
percentage on YouTube than here put it
up on both
but I think then you would have a
platform that kind of sets comedy free
in a way so it's a free I mean it would
only be free I mean making two million
dollars would be a lot more than losing
180 000 yeah please donate guys I'm
[ __ ] so broke
uh we're gonna make a nice donation to
it man just and to thank you for coming
too oh nice and for your time
um I got some 50s people don't need 50
bucks some people don't eat one and I'm
like that's great I get it you don't
have any money but you want to be like
that was good here's something I like
those is there a strong support from the
Jewish Community being Jewish do you
feel dude I thought it might go negative
and it's not in that it's been really
like people like this is awesome this is
clearly reverential to our society
making fun in a fun way
you know yeah what are the what are the
rules of that you can make fun of Jews
or not like or joke about it because
it's it's Tone If I'm like I'm like uh
if if you like I don't know if I say
like shut up Redneck you know you know
I'm joking there's a tone behind it
where some some other guy's like shut up
Redneck you'd be like hey hey right no
you know there's there's like you can
tell like friendliness it's tough to
tell
and even I guess and if a joke is good
too that helps to about if a joke
doesn't go over it seems more hateful
than if it does go over
like me Brian Dorfman and I always tell
jokes to each other right and uh he what
is one of my favorite ones it's like oh
what did the one Jewish guy say to you
it goes hey man I'm sorry to hear about
the fire and he goes it's Tuesday
that's what happened that's what Diaz
called Jewish lightning
the insurance he talked about some strip
club burning down on Sunset he goes dude
it caught fire it burns so much that the
bus stop outside on this on the sidewalk
melted that ain't no [ __ ] fire that's
where they went too hard on it it burned
harder than 911 dude which we also
planned
um yeah it's a good one that's one of my
favorite that's a good one remember the
lady from crackers uh yeah she well I
Tom Segura took me there he goes he goes
hey it's a break even week but it'll get
you in you know if you want to come
future for me uh it'll just pay for your
you know flights but she puts you in a
hotel so it's fine okay and she may
start running with Jew jokes and this is
I was on stage
should we throw Quarters at him
you give people the power to like Echo
nuts yeah that's true huh that's
interesting did um
did they
did you feel like a lot of the Kanye
stuff like did they did you have people
asking you about it oh yeah I think it
was probably miss Mis labeled what do
you think is going on with Kanye I don't
think he's happy with his agents he's
saying legitimately he's saying the same
[ __ ] that I've said for years you call
agents you're Jews I'm just call them
your Jews there's a lot of Jews in there
so it's a colloquial you know right my
literal agent is not Jewish but he's one
of my Jews
and when he goes I'm going Defcon on the
Jews he means he's going to fire his
agents he's just saying it he's an
artist he said he's not just going to
say I'm going to fire my agents that's
not fun I wish he'd do it through song
that's where he excels oh you know but
but like they're like these anti-semitic
statements like guys he doesn't they
write a narrative and then they go like
that narrative can't be wrong so let's
jump off from there I'm like I think
you're jumping off ground might be wrong
you know
it's oh he's Theo's wearing a purple
shirt so he's gay
um so as a gay man sitting here he has
to do this and I'm like wait you know I
not be right about the Gay Part can we
re-examine like it's a narrative it's
already set right and so I just don't
think he's that and then you're pushing
him deeper and deeper into like
defending himself you're pushing him to
be anti-semitic he might have had one
thought here that's a little off and now
you're making who's coming on who's
coming down on him the [ __ ] Jews are
coming down on them so now you're the
oppressor
uh I don't I just don't think it's all
that I think Kyrie Irving too is like I
saw a [ __ ] documentary yeah we've all
been there yeah he saw a flat Earth
documentary too and he liked that one
dude I'll tell you this the flat I'll
tell you how I even learn about Flat
Earth I'm at a pizza spot Palm Springs
two black dudes roll up on me they say
do you think that that pizza is round or
flat that's what they said interesting
it's both right and next thing you know
for one hour I'm sitting in an Italian
spot listening to Two Brothers tell me
about Flat Earth I'd love to hear that
here's my advice to everybody when you
meet a crazy person do not argue with
them yeah you've gained nothing you will
not change their opinion and you will
have lost the chance to hear their whole
crazy argument you meet a q Anon person
you go you're making some good points
what else you got just do your research
you won't get access like that that's a
good point you know if you get [ __ ]
Mike Shanahan going like uh can tell you
about some place like oh no those plays
don't work no just go okay I'm you're
listening just listen yeah so yeah by
the way literally every person I know
maybe outside Joe Rogan
cannot prove to you that the Earth is
round
I think it's round but I I can't tell
you what I would not be shocked if it
wasn't yeah I'd be like
I would not be shocked dude yeah who the
[ __ ] was Galileo
I don't even have [ __ ] Spotify that
was one thing that I thought was
interesting that Kanye said was about
like history like the people like
whoever owns the world or controls the
world history writes the history yeah
that's true fascinating dude because I
went to Cuba uh as a student I went to
Cuba and the bookstore is there they
start with when Fidel and Che uh had
control wow and you can't get a book you
can't get it that's like 1984 to rewrite
the history the um in the in Shanghai Ho
Chi Minh excuse me that's what they call
it
um
they have they they call it the American
war not the Vietnam War because it's
like this is just the Americans
attacking us are just one of the we just
drove out the French and then we had a
few years and the Americans came in
um they call it the war
reverence Museum
something like that and it's just about
the American incursion and it's like oh
yeah I guess you have a different angle
on it than we do hmm you were just
living your life and suddenly some
[ __ ] round eyes showed up start
pushing you around oh yeah weird yeah
it's interesting isn't it it's
interesting that like even in Rome
probably the Romans probably had the the
ability to write history yeah that's
what they're doing now when Rolling
Stones rewrites a list of like top
albums they're like well it's all white
albums with a few but it's like they
actually make really good music we
should re-examine that based on like you
know if I had to write top albums it'd
all be alt Rock
you know it wouldn't even be metal yeah
so I shouldn't be able to write it right
but if I was in charge it'd be all
Arcade Fire one through four yeah you
know I mean then the killers four
through eight you know
yeah so you need some other ideas in
there
yeah that's that's sometimes what I
think about Hollywood like that I
thought about Hollywood is like
I would go into a lot of meetings a lot
of pitches and stuff and it kind of felt
like the people had to say it was like
the same people yeah over a while you
know or the same mind like not even same
mindset yeah it's like it's like you
don't want a diversity of of experience
you know like we need some black people
it's like we'll go get Miss Pat and like
yeah that's not the kind of black we're
looking for
and like we'll go find them
it's not just like this it was like
whenever we did this not happening and
it's like we knew that this one is it
was the same list of minorities and I'm
like guys these these aren't good yeah
you gotta go look you gotta go to
Houston and find Ali I need a guy who
has n-word in his name you know yeah you
know what I'm saying like I need
somebody who's like you know what I'm
saying or I need somebody who Brother
Ali yeah or somebody who's TR like yeah
just I think that's one of the been one
of the the things about Hollywood that I
think puts us in a place like Quentin
Tarantino what did he just say if you're
able to find that up Zach
yeah he he just did an interview where
he said we're in the worst age of movies
of all time I agree if you wanted to do
a cop drama right now
from the 70s set in the 70s you couldn't
show the reality of that
so you're showing a fake version of it
or you're just like then do a cop drama
set now because you can't show the
reality so then it's like you ever
watched like a show when you were
growing up and all the cops like shut
the freak up and you're like all right
but you definitely didn't say freak a
lot yeah you know but it's like all
right there's sensors now there's like
sensors are even bigger
you can't just I mean when they did The
Comedy Store show uh whatever that was
that magical was on
oh is that when Adam
he could die no he didn't die who died
um it was about Mitzi and all that it
was like so I'm dying up here that's it
and then they in the middle of that they
had the metoo movement and they go well
let's show the women in the 70s being
strong and it's like well that's not
that's not what the [ __ ] show was
yeah and just in the middle of it they
were like oh this just got lame because
they're worried about [ __ ] presenting
a a case instead of just like presenting
the truth and something fun that's what
gets concerning to me is is is Hollywood
like are we starting to get to a point
where we're not even presenting the
truth what's really happening but also
because we don't it's the same type of
people in there that we don't know
what's they don't have a a firm just
like but they don't understand them so
they don't even know what they're taking
down right Sophie Buttle just had this
she she made a [ __ ] a joke in her
special and calling attention to the
[ __ ] rapes of indigenous people in in
Canada and somebody's like well you
should these are troubling things yeah I
know yeah so I'm bringing it up I've
been raped and I'm [ __ ] saying the
similarities between what they've been
going through are they [ __ ] crave TV
[ __ ] cave TV just [ __ ] took it
down she's getting all these death
threats and she goes I'm I'm on the
front lines of your [ __ ] cause and
you're coming after me are you [ __ ]
nuts they're so worried about they never
understand their issue and they just go
like ah get rid of it and you're like
it's your [ __ ] guy with the black guy
with the chef hat yeah who wants a
muffin yeah like you're racist like I'm
me it's crazy I know and then that's
when you start to fume up I think other
people who are like well quit [ __ ]
picking on me like uh yes I'm from the
south I like I'm not that guy but I'm
not that guy let's if we want to know
who did slavery you've got a black in
this chair yeah I know that hurt you and
you did it anyway
you had to disinfect this whole thing
but you're doing that because you're
looking to change Theo
be the change they call me Harvey
chocolate milk son we out here dog
um did you see that Dahmer thing
no you didn't watch it not yet oh God
no I heard a story about a friend of
mine
grew up in the midwest a long time ago
when I was in Yeshiva I was in seminary
but he went over to somebody's house and
uh he made a Dahmer joke you know
everybody got quiet you know where this
is going
what our cousin was one of the victims
and he goes oh I gotta like no it's okay
he goes no I gotta go I can't be here
anymore I'm so sorry and he left
Seminary no he told he was in seminary
told me the story
um it was just so uncomfortable
um
but you know wrong audience for sure but
it's probably still a good joke yeah
maybe yeah damn yeah that guy really did
it man yeah he really went for it he
believed in something
he didn't like gays man he loved him
he loved them
yeah but it was interesting he didn't
want people to leave him that's why he
did it so they'd stay forever wow
wow you know outside the box thinking
that's we need more of in this country
Jeffrey Dahmer hero spelled his name
with an H you know who would have
thought H in the middle of that who
would have thought eat
that guy [ __ ] outside the bombers
wouldn't that be crazy that would be
great oh zombies and it'd be like
burgers shaped like fingers and stuff
like you know a lot of chicken fingers a
lot of chicken fingers yeah chicken is
just wink the chicken's winking
come and get it we're going to Hades
um what else man what else is on your
mind are you anything else I am I don't
know let me think I'm just uh I'm gonna
look at some new Studios today oh really
I gotta get one I think so I'm excited
about that do you yeah I'm starting to
travel podcast and it's like I'm doing
it on my home I'll catch you on there
eventually when you have more time but
yeah I owe you are coming on so I'm
gonna come on there but I hate when
people like ah [ __ ] I'm busy I'm always
like then let's not do it like I'm not
looking at anybody get rushed but yeah I
think I want to get like a studio like
this I can go and like have some more
space would that be in New Yorker yeah
yeah and then I'll just get like a
backdrop I can put up in like a studio
like this I can just tape it up to the
wall or even like a thing a man told me
the other day I was at a breakfast place
and he goes you know what you you could
use maybe a certain piece of signage
where wherever you are you take that so
that just right like this and now it's
like theobon's world right you know so
it just insignifies there we are there
we are yeah I want to do some of these
I'm going to do this travel podcast and
uh it's called you be tripping you can
subscribe now but it's not coming out
yet but what I want to do is some of
them in a studio and some of them out
there in the world so if I meet some
traveler in [ __ ] Brazil and we're in
the rainforest I'm like dude let's shoot
right here this will be cool we're in
front of a waterfall yeah you know I did
one in a hostel in Paris with this guy
who's like traveling for [ __ ] a year
in just some hostile and I'm like this
is cool let's do it here this is a cool
setting it's not quite as good looking
as you know a studio like this but it
has some uniqueness and there's the the
there's the original element of of the
rogueness of it yeah there's that
podcast that's not a pie if you've seen
that podcast but outside have you seen
that Zach yeah they do they shoot it out
here on the street in L.A that's
interesting so each one is like who's
walking by I like shooting them outside
if I think if they they don't really go
it like I feel like they they're pretty
safe they keep things pretty safe on
there
uh I've seen them they were out on sale
oh damn they set up a chair and tables
podcasts but outside that's great I got
Don Draper one time that's great me and
me and Bobby Kelly we do this cigar
podcast two Comics two cigars and it's
just like me and Bobby Kelly are me and
Liz and we're just two Comics record a
[ __ ] podcast just with an iPhone and
[ __ ] clap it and just like smoke a
cigar and talk about it and then talk so
we did one at a cigar Plantation
um the foundation cigars and we just
went in the tobacco fields and we set
them up and did it and it just looks
cool in front of a field of tobacco yeah
it's on it's online yeah that one's up
there I think
two Comics two cigars yeah from
Foundation cigars Tabernacle I think
Kelly's so funny huh he's so funny he's
a nice guy that has a piece of [ __ ] but
he is very funny yeah that's him yeah
bad dog beats his dog too it's
uncomfortable but that's like part of
their culture you know Adam eager really
pulls his dog around the city I've seen
Yeah Austin it's almost like a yeah it's
like a it's almost like he like he
didn't make the reindeer thing or
something and he's like like his dog
like was gonna be a reindeer but he
didn't make it oh right right treat him
like that so then he's like your
disappointment to me yeah I was joking
about the Eagan is a piece of [ __ ] I
mean it's ever since Norm died he's kind
of died yeah he kind of killed him too
yeah Norma's like I shouldn't smoke he's
like just smoke what's the worst that
could happen you know yeah and then it's
like he found out I guess oh damn it's
sad it's sad oh my God all right if you
started your customer too who did
Holocaust on her are you good is he real
storm said it and look what happened to
him so actually can you cut that out I
don't want any trouble
yeah [ __ ] I don't want any trouble with
that guys you don't want any trouble if
your next special isn't called I don't
want to be in trouble
that's a good one I don't want any
trouble I think the name of a tour too
hey photoshoppers get on that yeah I
don't want any trouble to her you can
put me in all sorts of no dude Photoshop
for your photoshopper I think needs to
be sentenced your photoshopper makes me
[ __ ]
squishy and all these guys comedy
push-ups yeah I'm glad there's an outlet
man you know you provide I mean those
photoshops I put I'm just like hey go if
it makes me laugh or cringe I'm Bound by
the gods of Comedy to put it
who did that one uh that was start that
was short salad oh yeah start salad it's
just me yeah he's great it's just me
underneath if you're listening it's just
me underneath [ __ ] Nazi with a
[ __ ] German Shepherd on top and I'm
just hanging out into the [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] basement just go and watch my
special art Church what creativity what
[ __ ] creativity Ari shafir Jew is
there something about being Jewish that
other people don't understand because
I've always feel I can't understand I
heard there's a there's a theory that if
if you're more than 60 IQ points away
from someone else you actually can't
communicate oh really yeah so you people
like you will never understand damn you
know the boys yeah yeah
damn dude but you know is it is it by
example do people look at being Jewish
like is it
because there's also a thing where like
there's like Jewish hate like Jewish
like self-loathing or whatever yeah
self-hating Jews that's that yeah what
is that it's like
you're just like I hate that in this
thing but ugh is a Jewish thing right
you know we invented
um dude when we were starting comedy we
had a self-hating gay and that was his
act no he's like I know I'm getting it's
disgusting oh wait I think I know him
was it um he's a seancer Now isn't he is
he really yeah I think uh it was the
most interesting unique take of
literally any comic in my entire career
he was so good I think he hated himself
it was and he was presented that to the
stage of a self-hating guy didn't deny
being gay
but thought he was evil for having these
thoughts
it was so honest well is it so is that
something about because I'm just trying
to think if there's stuff about you
about Judaism that I don't understand
I'm sure there's a lot of things right
yeah but is there something about it
that like
well like racially no just like
that is their
because I had two as friends that always
they just like it they seem like you
know like
overwhelmed sometimes maybe like is it
that's not the word oh yeah it's the
inbreeding I talk about this in a
special like oh there's inbreeding it's
all inbreeding so we're failing like
bodily we're like falling apart you know
oh wow yeah we have specific diseases
that are made just for Jews and they did
it from inbreeding yeah too much
inbreeding we've been [ __ ] ourselves
for too long you need outside jeans or
kids not one outside jeans is that look
down upon yeah it's just like you only
[ __ ] Jews but then it's like well that's
a limited gene base you know I mean
Iceland is even more limited and they
have an app that shows if you're
somebody's cousin no yeah you have to go
to the app
so it's like it's a bigger scale of that
but if you can [ __ ] anybody well now
we've got all sorts of genes it's like
the Ian Edwards bid the hottest people
are like halfs you know yeah yeah get
two ugly parents from different races
the kid is [ __ ] gorgeous so you get
two parents of exactly the same thing
the kid is [ __ ] you know disease
ridden oh yeah uh big noses [ __ ]
balding
so do you have to marry a Jewish person
or you don't have to I'm out you know
but yeah you're supposed to you're
supposed to also not eat bacon but damn
it's good
yeah bacon you guys got that one right
the L to you who wants to just an LT who
wants an LT yeah what the [ __ ] with that
lettuce and tomato on bread what what
save your life
what's an LT
um will people learn about being Jewish
from your special yeah they will they'll
learn a lot mostly it's just there to
laugh you're just there to laugh it's
kind of like I compared to like Brian
Regan or Nate bargatzi where they're
clean comics but that's got nothing to
do with it you're just there laughing
the whole time and they're like oh did
you not curse I guess he didn't it's
like you're just gonna laugh it's just a
special you will learn a bunch
um a bunch
but it's it's every one of these bits I
say like you gotta these bits have to be
good enough to follow Norman at the
stand yeah you know God he's good he's
so good he's so good
um Ari shaffir Jew you can check it out
on YouTube you can donate there after
you watch it
um yeah dude I'm excited everyone's
really liking it pass it around [ __ ]
play a Thanksgiving for your family and
Christmas you know bring people together
it's it's something that you can talk
about it and like I'm loving people I've
never had this in my career people like
I I play this for my dad or I sent my
dad and we talked about it wow it's
generally like [ __ ] my dad walked in the
room I had to turn it off
now is that enlarging your heart a
little bit because you've always had a
little bit of this kind of uh a little
bit of not Grinch but this Grinch I like
that yeah and that's the wrong word pull
up Grinch was it Theodore diesel was a
Jew yeah oh really yeah yeah
that's what I was named after really
yeah that tell me that's not a [ __ ]
one of mine actually he's got a really
tiny nose I might be wrong on that um
but the back hair the back area
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
then you have you are there
um orange if you're man thank you so
much for uh continuing to make comedy
man for being a part of uh for just not
even giving up on yourself when things
were tough I'm sure bro the comedy start
training she beat us down too much she
can't beat us down anymore I I had an
old lady made me cry so many times and
now it's just like [ __ ] get how much
you've been through yeah she made me
that's what I saw in Ayahuasca I talked
to Mitzi for real really talk to her in
the fire and she was like I prepared you
for all of this I wasn't just a [ __ ] for
no reason I was getting you ready it was
basic training yeah it's orgasm
meditation baby
um thank you so much man all right
tank you can check them out you can
check them out with uh Robert Kelly
um on the two cigars two Comics two
cigars and uh you're tripping road
tripping you'll be tripping just
subscribe now it's not out yet it'll
probably on January February you'll be
tripping subscribe now and go see him
whenever he goes to tour he's back
Dallas
uh Vancouver Seattle's coming uh
Pittsburgh Salt Lake uh San Jose are
they on your website they're on my
website we'll put it up right here wait
yeah thank you bro
I feel I'm falling like these leaves I
must be
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life I found I
can feel
it in my bones
but it's gonna take